hey guys I'm Ryan right hey good I'm
Sally Lomonaco we're gonna watch a
trailer for into the storm into the
storm
I'm trying to limit my sex jokes around
Sally I'm really trying okay that
serious talk with simple but I'm gonna
try to limit sex jokes around her to be
respectful and courteous to her so
there's going to be no into the storm
sex jokes about my pure imagination but
trust me I have a lot of jokes of what I
could use as puns of into the storm as
sexual references but I'm not going to
do that today great how to respect so
just a heads up like I kind of notice
about it seems like another twister like
a newer twister well what I think what I
got from the other trailer was how it
was like there's a lot of these disaster
movies were like all over the [ __ ]
planet yeah and this is like a disaster
movie in the moment yeah it's like
you're in that journey of that one place
you know and so that that's what looks
unique about it to me
okay well that's pg-13 for sequences of
intense destruction in peril and
language including some sexual
references Wow sexual references they
brought I made the same jokes new
everybody I know
[ __ ] people stole my jokes for this
intense thriller I leave you with Henry
David Thoreau's words go confidently in
the direction of your dreams live the
life you have a man
whoa
we got this Ruggeri
did you hear that I gotta get my son can
you take this hose that
so you guys do for women hey Jase I
study
and it was close dude
there's another one
I study stories
this one is bigger than any storm it is
a big
my god
oh my god no that scares the crap out of
me because I lived in Florida where it
rains constantly we had tornado warnings
all the time in school we'd constantly
have to do like tornado the drills the
2000 drills and that was one thing that
always like terrified me as a kid fact
that like there could be a tornado but
they can just sweep us up when we just
suffocate in the air and not just
terrifies yeah I know what you mean I
mean this kind of reminds me of gravity
in the sense that like they're like hey
anything that what is like the worst
possible space experience okay yeah like
what's the worst possible tornado story
yeah this is this is really going deaf
and make them feel in the part of that
storm and yeah it is like uncomfortable
to watch actually when I get
uncomfortable I laugh but that [ __ ]
moment what are there in the tunnel I
was like oh my god is too much this is a
little too much for me now it just
scares me because I've been under
hurricane before and you have yes whoa
and that was like one of the scariest
moments of my life because it was
category four and our whole entire house
was shaking and you look at the sky and
it's actually we were in the eye of the
hurricane it was actually red I've never
seen a red sky before and it just like
swirl so it's kind of like a big tornado
in my opinion and it's the scariest
thing you have no control over the winds
and there there were trees completely
uprooted out of out of the ground in my
neighborhood every single tree and it
was terrifying knowing that just wind is
kicking can you kill so many people and
put like it's not laughing I don't know
I don't know put a freaking bicycle in
someone's car like it's crazy yeah I'm
sorry I don't know the traumatic
experience for you but the whole time
you kept saying things where I could
have been like that's what she said or
something and I just want you to be a
little bit more courteous right because
you know this is a process for me it's
not you know makes me okay
the deep long did no it's a yes long
just penetrating brothers yes it is I'm
not making any sex jokes sarami like
come on mm-hmm be respectful facade the
would you go see it yeah dude I love
movies that just put me into another
experience no matter how scary they are
I like that Nathan presses in there the
kid from icarly I couldn't seen him do
anything old system I didn't recognize
anyone chick from The Walking Dead I
didn't recognize someone
yeah really say that out loud okay yeah
well thank you guys for recommending
this trailer to us it was a good trailer
we approve I just hope that the
characters are still as intriguing as
the ones in twister yes and it's not
just a really bad action remake of
history anyway guys if you're new to the
channel says I subscribe we're asking
you a personal favor here if you
subscribe good things will happen for
you I saw they won't do anything sexual
don't worry okay I got a slight boo
grades nope I did not care and I didn't
feel anything
it was wow I did not get a little horny
just now yeah okay respect a sucker
punch my balls please give me a
shout-out Ryan I'll be the second guy to
suck your dick huh actually you be
number four my friend number four I
don't remember any of their names
oh wow like you oh god no I don't know
when it comes to that okay
not when it comes in theme well doesn't
[ __ ] nothing's gay about
yeah it's the same thing actually no
that cantaloupe is this like advice you
give your boyfriend no here's a
cantaloupe for what I'm gone watermelon
yeah I'll be the second guy to suck your
dick
okay well dude if you want to suck my
dick cool just send me a photo let me
make sure you look okay I don't really
like facial hair and another guy and
it's kind of selfish because I have
Fichtner but I don't really like facial
hair another guy cuz you know when
you're like sucking my dick gonna land I
like touch your face and then feel that
here I want you to feel as feminine as
possible basically that's all I like
he'd prefer it if you were a girl pretty
much aim for my head 81 he said shout
out please I'm a loyal subscriber thanks
I like both of these were like all
capital letters I know they really were
meaning this so yeah and for my head 81
you're uh you're someone special to me I
want you to know that you know like
you're so boy I aim for your head
I want that joke it's not directed at
Sally it's just made in front of her
doesn't mean I'm being disrespectful and
it makes remained a loyal subscriber my
friend
yeah frodo baggins you said right hit me
up with a shout-out
ptew you duh [ __ ] man wow you
capitalized [ __ ] dad you are to
emphasize his point how cool I am he
capitalized the word [ __ ] mm-hmm that's
really cool of you man thank you very
much you're a good guy Frodo Baggins
you helped out the world what did you
like did us a service if you didn't go
through that journey that struggle like
dude we'd be [ __ ] also if you didn't
film the whole entire struggle that you
went through like I wouldn't even want
to be doing film with my life so thank
you like handshake man you're great
you're you're an American Hero from the
middle right